>>Teacher: One, two, sing strong.
Go.
>>Class: Listen to the water, listen
to the water, rolling down the river.
Listen to the water,
listen to the water--
>>Narrator: It begins
in the first grade,
and continues in middle school.
>>Teacher: What's the
mood of this music?
>>Narrator: It culminates in high
school bands and orchestral groups,
infusing the entire curriculum
of the Bay Shore school district
on New York's Long Island.
Here students learn to read, write
and revel in the medium of music.
>>Evelyn: You're not educated
if you don't have the arts.
Even in difficult times,
we try to make sure
that our students have
access to the arts.
It's part of the air we breathe.
We're so close to New
York and we have access
to so many wonderful
cultural opportunities here
and we want our children to
have those opportunities.
>>Teacher: You have to know how
to harmonize "Jingle Bells."
You start on E and use your ear.
>>Narrator: The district has been
providing musical opportunities
to all its students for decades,
and has been recognized as one
of the country's top music
programs by the Grammy organization.
>>Class: One little, two
little, three little robots.
>>Narrator: Children begin
to benefit from an exposure
to music in the first grade.
>>Student: Ta.
Tee, ta, ta.
>>Carol: That's it.
>>I think music is really important
in all areas of their development.
When we work on movement,
it helps in the area of PE,
and the gross motor skills.
Rhythms help them with coordination,
playing the instruments also.
We work on singing.
We're doing reading, because
they're reading the lyric charts.
They have to read from left to right.
All kinds of different skills
that generalize into other areas
of their academic schedule.
>>Narrator: At Bay Shore, every third
grader gets to choose and instrument
and take five weeks of
free summer lessons.
And all students take a general
music class, where they learn
to appreciate the classics
and the basics of composition.
Technology also helps high school
students pursue their passion
for music.
>>Teacher: This is an
advanced composition class,
and the final projects for the
end of the year is a requirement
that they submit a major work.
>>Terry: Computers have turned
out to be an extremely powerful
and extremely flexible
tool for creativity.
And it's really not
about the computers
or the software or the gadgets.
It's really about the
creative process.
>>Teacher: We'll talk about voicings.
Like right now, this is kinda
muddy, but if you take these notes
and you move them up an octave,
now you can clear your voicing.
So now we're talking
about orchestration.
And it's instant.
Now they can hear it back and forth,
you know, as you're demonstrating it.
>>[orchestra playing]
>>Narrator: In addition to conducting
the advanced musical groups,
Ted Scalzo teaches classes
in music composition
and multimedia production.
>>Ted: What makes multimedia
unique is the empowerment.
First of all, they're given projects
where they realize
they're high profile.
Someone's gonna look at this.
Somebody's gonna be using it.
Someone's maybe gonna need it
some day and I think when you set
that high mark, that this isn't
just a class, we're treating you
like pros a little bit, you
gotta produce something that,
when it goes out into the
public, it's consumable.
>>Narrator: Students use
their own musical compositions
to complement their
personal productions.
>>Molly: This is my final film
for my film studies project.
I know a lot of schools
don't have these programs
and I'm very privileged to be
part of Bay Shore High School
and having these programs, such as
multimedia and our music department.
>>Narrator: Every year in June,
Bay Shore puts on an arts festival,
which helps raise money for the music
programs this community has come
to embrace.
For the student musicians, this
is the final exam they relish.
>>You know, that feeling
of getting on stage.
This is the moment.
There's no going back.
There's only forward.
You're gonna produce something,
and what you produce is going
to either communicate
or not communicate.
You're either gonna move or
you're not gonna move an audience.
So they learn about pressure,
they learn about putting
themselves on the spot.
They learn about preparing
and training for the event,
very much like an athlete
in a lotta ways.
>>Terry: I think music and all
of the arts benefit
children in many, many ways.
The aspect of discipline,
of studying really hard,
focusing on achieving something.
There are cognitive
benefits, decoding skills.
Everybody's part is important.
You can't just have one
or two great players.
Everybody's gotta play the
right note at the right time.
Once you expose children to music
and the arts at an early age,
they take that with them
for the rest of their life.
And what I love about it
is that everybody wins.
>>Ted: Oh, let's do
that ending again.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.